mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
triangle abc has an inscribed circle i
the inscribed circle is tangent to bc at
point d
if the radius of the inscribed circle is
15 bd is equal to 26 and dc is equal to
25
what is the area of triangle abc
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i'm first going to review the concepts
used to solve this problem
these will be equal tangents to a circle
the area of a triangle from its in
radius and heron's formula for the area
of a triangle
we'll get started with equal tangents to
a circle
consider circle p and an exterior point
a
construct tangents a b and a c
we want to show that a b is equal to ac
to do that we'll construct radii pb and
pc
we then construct ap
it's obvious now that abp and acp are
congruent right triangles
to be more explicit notice that ap is a
hypotenuse length w
therefore the remaining leg in the right
triangle will be equal to the square
root of w squared minus r squared and
that's true in both of these right
triangles
therefore a b is exactly equal to ac
now let's derive the area of a triangle
from its in radius
in a triangle with sides abc
consider the inscribed circle
draw radii to each of the points of
tangency
we can therefore partition the triangle
into three smaller triangles
one triangle will be alongside a
this triangle will have an area of a r
over 2. this triangle alongside b will
have an area of b r all over 2.
finally the triangle alongside c has an
area of c r all over 2.
we can simplify this formula and then
factor out the r
we thus have r multiplied by the
perimeter all over 2.
the perimeter over 2 is known as the
semi-perimeter and often abbreviated as
s
therefore the formula is r times s
finally
we have herron's formula for the area of
a triangle
it'll be equal to the following
expression the square root of s
multiplied by s minus a multiplied by s
minus b multiplied by s minus c
here s again is the semi perimeter
i'll now briefly give a proof of heron's
formula
by elkashi's law of cosines c squared is
equal to a squared plus b squared minus
two a b multiplied by the cosine of
angle c
in this equation we'll solve for the
cosine of angle c
we'll then use the identity that the
sine of angle c is equal to the square
root of one minus the cosine squared of
the angle c
we substitute that in and then simplify
we then use the formula that the area of
a triangle is equal to one half a b
multiplied by the sine of angle c
again we substitute and simplify
we're now going to use a lot of algebra
to simplify this equation
first we have a difference of squares so
we can factor it as follows
we're then going to factor each of these
terms
and then we have another difference of
squares so we factor each of these
quantities
we then simplify this formula
now we're going to take that 1 4 and put
it inside as 1 over 16.
we can distribute this to each of the
four terms because 2 to the power 4 is
equal to 16.
finally the semi-perimeter is equal to a
plus b plus c all over 2.
so the first term will be s the second
term will be s minus c the third term
will be s minus a and the last term will
be s minus b
we substitute those in and then we
slightly rearrange this formula and we
get exactly heron's formula we've proven
it
so now let's use each of these concepts
to solve the problem
first equal tangence
bd must be equal to bf therefore bf is
equal to 26.
then cd and ce are equal tangents
therefore c e is equal to 25.
here if af is equal to x a e must also
be equal to x
consequently side a b is 26 plus x
ac is 25 plus x
and bc is equal to 26 plus 25 which is
equal to 51. we will now calculate the
area of triangle abc in two different
ways first we'll calculate its area from
the in radius
we first calculate the semi-perimeter
this will be the perimeter of the
triangle all over 2.
this simplifies to be 51 plus x
the area will be r times s which will be
equal to 15 multiplied by the quantity
51 plus x
we'll put this equation to the side
we then use heron's formula
so we have the formula
we've calculated the semi perimeter and
we substitute in to get the area of the
triangle in this form
we thus have two equations for the area
of the triangle which we set equal to
each other
we now systematically solve this
equation to solve for the variable x
this is basic algebra
so i'll just go through it quickly
we then end up with x is equal to 27 but
we're not trying to solve for x we're
trying to solve for the area of the
triangle so we go back to the formula
for the area and then substitute and we
get the answer of one thousand one
hundred and seventy
i love this problem involves so many
different concepts from geometry
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you